a mysterious group known simply as the
hunters are one of the few enemies that
the division have encountered so far
they have the ability to intimidate and
overpower the highly-trained agents they
move and fight in an almost identical
way to the operatives of the shd where
they have one major difference rather
than fighting for the community and
restoring order from those who wish to
harm it this all-purpose seems to be a
hunt down the division agents and
slaughter them in a brutal merciless
fashion
[Music]
continuing on from a video released
almost 12 months ago I wanted to revisit
the hunters based on the new information
that could be found in the division - I
use the word information very loosely
because at this stage we still haven't
actually been given any law on these
guys so before I get into anything I
want to state that this video much like
the last is going to be based on theory
or hypothesis if you really want to get
technical about it these theories will
be based on other law within the
division and how they've been introduced
alongside the main story and the way
they look and act and game there are
hundreds of ideas and speculation out
there but I'm only going to cover the
main ones that come up the ones they
have some good points behind them I'll
try to look into the pros and cons of
each and then add my own take to each
theory mostly when it comes to the
Division one there are a couple of
hunter instances that all right off as
simply non-canon non story related
content with the legendary missions that
can be seen fighting alongside the main
factions and this is also present in the
resistance mode of the game hunters were
obviously introduced to these activities
to add another layer of difficulty later
on in the game in saying that it's
possible that the hunters were only
added to the game as a new challenging
foe to battle it out against with no
backstory but that wouldn't make much of
a video now would it here I'd like to
speculate on the what-ifs and how things
could be affected based on certain
outcomes
as we all know Aaron kena ended up
escaping New York City along with Gordon
Amherst protein printer and Russian
scientist Vitali tenneco he effectively
has everything he needs to recreate the
virus during survival
apart from escaping the city before
dying from their injuries agents were
also tasked with retrieving antivirals
from the dark zone and this is when we
first introduced to the hunters Gina has
plans to remake the virus possibly even
more deadly than it was before
the last thing he wants is for the
second wave agents to get their hands on
these antivirals assisting in the
creation of a cure removing any leverage
she currently has kina has some of his
top rogue agents trained up into these
new division hunting machines their task
to kill all division agents on site this
is probably one of the most popular
theories out in the community Erin
keener was the main antagonist in the
division one naturally you'd expect any
new and dangerous hostiles to have been
related to him some sort of way but
there are a few things that just don't
seem to work with this idea we need to
remember that between the time that the
agents went rogue and the survival
update that brought up the hunters not a
lot of time has passed in-game there
wouldn't been enough time to train up
these new top rogue agents into the new
second way of killing machines we've all
found first way of agents before they
can be seen roaming around New York City
with squads of LMB although tough
opponents they certainly out to the same
caliber of the hunters on top of this
the hunters have examples of shd tech
that is superior to what the first or
second wave had been running for example
the Jemma's where did this come from and
how would it be manufactured in the
short period of time within the duck sir
shortly after Aaron Keena turned rogue
and started recruiting other first wave
agents into his cause
killing anyone that refused the word got
out agents unwilling to site with kina
winner - Heidi and cut all
communications with the shd and other
agents as a way to stop themselves from
being hunted down they're trapped in the
dark zone and have no idea who they can
trust the j-tier from the government
pulled out and anyone left behind was a
potential hostile because they cut
communications with the shd they have no
idea about the second wave agents being
released for this reason they treat all
agents they come across as the same part
of kinas crew they're still good people
and don't harm civilians they're just
fighting for their own survival the
reason for showing up during the storm
was because of a couple of reasons one
they were able to conceal themselves
relatively easily to strike when they
were ready and two they could see that
the agents were wounded the brutality at
which they fight is just an act of
revenge for these agents revenge for
kina and his rogues betrayal of the
community that they all lived in the shd
and the government I kind of like the
idea of this one agents stuck in the
dark zone alone being hunted down by
their former colleagues it sounds like
the start of an action film
I find myself swaying more towards this
one than the last mainly because they're
alone they're having to fend for
themselves very quickly they're likely
to hone in on some of their skills and
the ones that don't are quickly found
and killed so the ones that are left are
the toughest of the bunch but this still
doesn't explain the different shd tech
and where it came from
also it doesn't really tell us why
they've traveled to Washington DC
perhaps they're in too deep maybe they
heard the distress call and decided to
rejoin the fight as affection of their
own the black tusk has been working in
the shadows since long before the
division agents knew of their existence
in fact only a short period of time
after the outbreak they were employed by
an unknown organization to start
preparing an invasion on the US Capitol
while security forces have been brought
to the knees combating the spread of the
virus the black tusk has a long history
of working with shadowy portions of the
government and have been involved in
handling conflict zones across the world
with their primary directives to be to
cleanse pacify and police the emerging
new America a black tusk are well aware
of the division and have been watching
them since they were activated as though
a needing to keep their identity hidden
until they were ready to show their hand
they sent in a special ops unit known
only as the hunters the black tusk have
been employed by an organization who
ties deep inside the US government for
this reason they're well aware of the
shd
and how to compare
the hunters have been specially trained
to take down division agents the reason
for their involvement early on was to
stop second wave agents from achieving
their goal to allow the green poison to
continue to spread and to keep the
security forces of the u.s. busy this
ideas be gaining traction says the end
game of the division 2 was first opened
up to the community the black tusk has
very similar technology to the shd so
they're more than capable of equipping a
hunter with the type of skills they've
been known to use they're also quite
well-versed at working in the shadows an
attribute that the hunters have well
mastered this would also explain their
need to conceal their identity using
masks the only thing that doesn't sit
with me quite right as the hunters
behaviour in DC it's possible they were
brought into the capital to assist in
taking down division agents but the
black Tufts special unit didn't seem to
be having any troubles doing that on
their own in DC they just seemed to be a
little less motivated it's like they
were wandering around aimlessly unsure
of what to do
maybe they'll stud down after the BTS
commander ordered a stop to the killing
of division agents but why does the
first one we come across kill agent
Edwards and they'll leave us alive after
knocking us into a shocked paralysis
type state although there is far more to
the story I can easily see this being of
possibilities to what the undeserved
though I do feel this would be quite an
anticlimactic into this mystery
[Music]
Russian personnel quickly evacuated New
York City after the outbreak however
somehow Vitaly Taneka was left behind
Vitaly contacted the Russian government
and offered his knowledge on the green
poison for an extraction out of the city
the Russian government decided to help
not just to bring Vitaly back but also
to secure the servers in the basement of
the Russian consulate because of the
quarantine and the lockdown of the
island they had to send in a force of
specially trained units to sneak in the
spirits nests but before they got there
KYNA strokes had broken in and taken
Vitaly hostage the Russian unit hunted
down all division agents in an attempt
to find information on Aaron keener the
hunters use shd tech and weapons that
they have stolen from agents they've
killed the SH D Tech is the most
powerful thing that the agents have at
their disposal but it would also raise
the question as to who they actually are
same with the weapons and the face masks
and the fact that they don't ever talk
it's all about concealing their identity
the last thing they want to do is to
start Nix World War they hold on to the
watches of the agents they've killed as
a way of listening out for
communications and tracking agents in
hopes that they'll hear something about
Keena this theory has been around as
long as the hunters in my last video I
dismiss this relatively quickly
one reason was because the evidence and
ideas for this theory were pretty weak
mostly it was based around them only
using Russian weapons of which we know
isn't true and a loosely strung together
story around the Russian government
wanting to take advantage of the u.s.
city of New York
while it was crippled by the dollar flow
and the other reason it just felt way
too cliche I think I just really didn't
want the story of the hunters to go down
that typical path of every action film
of the 90s of just blaming it on the
Russians but 12 months have passed and a
few members of the community like bye
and vigilance have helped clarify this
theory further I would have pointed out
the fact of the hunters use s HD tech
and only members of the sh t have access
and the ability to use it but we now
know this isn't true we can even see an
agent handing over his watch to a
civilian in one of the pre released
trailers we know that the virus is
worldwide but there are a number of
recordings and Intel in the division to
their show the majority of the impact
that has been caused by the virus so far
has been isolated to the United
dates furthermore they have a good
reason for being in DC using the sh d
tic bounders like the rest of the
division agents found out that aaron
keener has moved into washington DC this
is why the hunters can be seen
throughout the city watching from the
rooftops they're continuing their search
for keener and tanika but like every
other theory there's still a number of
questions and things that still don't
quite make sense the overall way the
parent is act in the division too has
shifted dramatically given that their
overall goal hasn't changed shouldn't
they still be trying to hunt division
agents down as ferociously and brutally
as before in the division - it's like
they'd rather not get into combat with
us at all they fight back when we engage
them but it's not so uncommon to see
them moving away from us during these
battles it feels like we're the ones
calling the shots now and they're just
simply trying to defend themselves but
even with these questions so it goes far
to say this is probably one of the most
robust hunter theories out there at the
moment
plus they certainly wouldn't be the
first time that a Tom Clancy game has
brought Russia into the story
as a title holding the Tom Clancy name
there are a number of other games they
have very similar groups to the hunter's
Bois d'Arc is a Russian spirit sness
unit that was comparable to the ghosts
in Ghost Recon highly trained and
disciplined their name comes from the
myth of men that choose to become wolves
first seen in Ghost Recon alpha and then
future Soldier the logo shows a very
close resemblance to the hunter logo
like the hunters of Russian Special
Forces theory the boudic have been
deployed to hunt down kena killing any
agents that come across in hopes of
finding information the ghosts are an
elite special mission unit with the new
United States Army armed with
state-of-the-art weapon systems and
trained in the best field and combat
tactics they are the most specialized
operation unit the Joint Special
Operations Command has to offer their
experience with striking enemies swiftly
silently and invisibly making them the
perfect counter to the shd agents this
idea is a bit of a roll on from the
Russian theory but also includes other
characters shown at Tom Clancy titles
like the ghosts from Ghost Recon my
knowledge on other Tom Clancy games is
pretty good but I still don't think it
was quite good enough to be able to
fully answer this theory not to the
extent that I'd like to so I enlisted
the help of a local expert on Tom Clancy
law drei Gnaeus has been a member of our
community for probably the last year or
so and is fairly active on our discord
he is my go-to guy for information and
advice on Tom Clancy law outside of the
division when it first came to him with
us he responded with a massive amount of
detail on crossovers between most of if
not all Tom Clancy games I mean I could
probably take this information and make
another half dozen videos on this topic
alone so rather than spending the next
thirty minutes going over some of the
information I'm simply going to sum it
up with the division is a standalone
game in its own Tom Clancy universe
separate from the other games right back
before the release of the first game I
actually recall a podcast where the
developers confirmed this the reason the
division was given the Tom Clancy name
was because of the heavily story-driven
a more realistic nature of this
franchise but even without hearing that
the timelines of the various games just
don't really match up especially given
the worldwide epidemic that has occurred
in the division
there are many strong connections
between games like Ghost Recon Rainbow
six Splinter Cell and Hawks these games
make a point to show the connection
leaving nothing to chance the closest
we've found with the division is with
the recording collectibles that can be
found at wild lands right before the
division 2 was released but this was
very obviously a promotions and
marketing ploy from the team at ubisoft
they've done this a number of times with
other games and it's actually quite a
clever way of marketing upcoming titles
but it certainly didn't alter the story
in any way for either game now I'm not
saying they weren't changed their minds
and joined some of these games in the
future but this certainly is nothing
showing that they're considering it
right now but let's say that these games
are connected the characters suggested
still don't quite fit in with their own
background ghosts of specialist units
trained to operate in a team each had
different positions and roles within the
group yes they're more than capable of
operating on their own but this is not
what they're trained to do secondly as
the name suggests they get in and out as
fast as possible and leave no trace
behind they kill if they have to but
they're trained to do it quickly and
quietly given the way that the hunters
are looking for our agents and the Missy
way they choose to finish us off it
really doesn't fit in with the Ghost
Recon character
the idea behind bode arc is that they
were the ones been sent in by the
Russian government the oh man appearance
was in Ghost Recon Future Soldier yes
there are Russian special forces unit
similar to the ghosts but many if not
all of them actually align themselves
with the Russian separatist group Raven
wrong Raven Rock went on to successfully
take over the Russian government but
it's unlikely they would have deployed
overseas because they actually ended up
losing the government position later on
the first wave agents were deployed into
New York City shortly after the dollar
flew was released into the world they
were there to support the JTF with
containing the virus in the dark zone
and regaining control of the city
shortly after they were activated the
JTF and government pulled out in the
dark zone leaving the first wave and
thousands of infected to fend for
themselves this eventually led to the
uprising of Kino and his group of rogues
after this the second wave was released
unfortunately most of them were
destroyed before even sitting foot in
Manhattan however it was a contingency
plan the shd had an alternate plan for
if things went wrong with the division a
third wave the division agents in New
York City were lost most of Eva died or
gone rogue and the ones that have
managed to avoid Keener and his crew
were privy to far too much information
around the shd and the government's
failures at executing the plan the third
wave was comprised of a special task
force who was equipped to take down
division agents barring any evidence of
what had happened alternatively the
third wave wasn't shd at all there's
still a US government task force but it
been purposely kept separate from the
shd due to what they were intended for
rather than a civilian agency the
hunters are from a military agency they
have been trained in the existence of
the shd and have been given similar tech
to use with features that overpower what
the division agents have been given
still to be used as a method of cleaning
up loose ends however this group is only
given the information the agents have
turned against the country and need to
be eliminated the hunters being the
third wave was my preferred theory 12
months ago but given what we've seen
with the introduction of the division -
it doesn't quite fit as well as it used
to instead of being part of the sh t
themselves who would make more sense if
these were a different government agency
all together the division agents are
privy to a lot of classified information
including the existence of the SH D in
the first place they've seen how the
government has handled things rightly
and wrongly the idea that the hunters
were sentient to remove the division
because they went rogue might not
necessarily be true maybe it was the
plan all along after my video on how a
division agents chosen a lot of people
ask the obvious question of but what
happens to these agents when they return
back to normal life but they didn't
allow to explain everything they've been
a part of
what I'm suggesting is that maybe they
were never meant to return to normal
life maybe they were to be cleaned up
after the job was done and being that
it's a separate military branch of the
government the shd command have no idea
of this so a separate hidden military
unit is sent in to wipe them out making
it look like they was simply killed in
the line of duty by one of the many
hostile factions around they aren't
given any information around the targets
just that there needed to be eliminated
the reason I've shown up in New York
well before the agents completed their
mission may have been because of the
rogue agents and the deviation from the
overall plan well maybe it has some to
do with the constantly shifting power
within the White House we know that a
large number of top government personnel
were evacuated from DC we know that a
number of government personnel were
killed when Air Force One was shot out
of the sky
we also know that we're on to our third
president since the outbreak mostly due
to internal struggles and outside
influences from a mysterious
organization that has employed the black
tusk so what if the leading force behind
the hunter agency was killed during this
time sure they could have been telling
us to step into their shoes but what if
they were also taken out there wouldn't
have been a huge number of people that
were knowledgeable of the hunters of
existence vilest than even the shd
especially given their purpose or maybe
the command has now been infiltrated by
the same organization that turned on
president Ellis so the hunters followed
the distress call to Washington DC where
they've lost communications with the
command and are now facing a new enemy
that seems to be functioning from the
same level at which they'd received
their orders the hunters were seeing in
DC were just the remaining of what was
activated in New York nor the hunters
have been activated since it's possible
that they are aware of the issues that
are happening within the leadership of
the country and they are simply waiting
to find out what the new orders are now
I'm going to really put on my tinfoil
hat maybe Erin Keena already knows of
all this maybe he found out what was
installed for the division agents once
they've completed the missions it could
go even deeper than that like the real
people and purpose behind the original
outbreak there is a very slight
possibility that Erin Kino is actually
the hero we all need but don't deserve
but this is probably a theory of mine
better suited to another video maybe
I'll talk about that a bit later on
so do you have it these are my thoughts
on the current theories floating around
plus a few editions of my own all of
these can be picked apart in one way or
another but based on a little
information we have each of them are
completely possible I've tried to pack
in as many ideas as I could under each
Theory most of them out there are just
adaptations of these six different
speculations for example I think I
covered about five or six in the third
wave section a part of me actually hopes
that the hunters backstory never gets
revealed we've built up so much hype
around them that their actual origins
will likely disappoint plus it's the
mystery around them that really sets
them apart even if you disagree with
every single theory here at the very
least I hope I've opened up your mind to
the large number of possibilities around
not just the hunters but some of the
other mysteries within the division
before I go I really must thank drainie
us for all the help you gave me with
this video you can find him in a discord
but also a breaks and little cooks from
Notley in gaming for a lot of the
in-game footage part of it was from
early on when we first found out you
could activate the hunters we didn't
really have any gear and they ended up
chasing us all the way into the safe
house where they decided to hang out for
a little while anyway both of their
channels will be listed in the
description if you get a chance please
jump in and Chuck some energy and love
their way in fact let's see if we can
spam one of their videos if you enjoyed
this and like the sort of video or
Theory crafting please let me know I had
a lot of fun putting this one together
thanks for watching guys Cheers
knowing all agents we haven't inbound
blizzard warning we have to get the cure
and get out before the storm hit
you